>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
[Musik]
İstanbul'a hoş geldiniz!
Wir sind gerade hier in Istanbul, direkt am Bosporus.
Hinter mir seht ihr die Bosporus-Brücke.
Und es ist gerade atemberaubend schön.
Das Wetter ist warm.
Es ist ein leichter Wind.
Also wirklich wunderschön!
Am liebsten würde ich den Moment einfrieren
und für immer hierbleiben.
Mit Samira und Ela natürlich.
Es hat auch einen bestimmten Grund,
dass wir gerade in Istanbul sind.
Denn hier in Istanbul oder überhaupt in der Türkei
gibt es wirklich ganz viele deutsche Marken, die man kennt.
Jedes zweite, dritte Auto kommt aus Deutschland.
Es gibt Küchengeräte hier.
Und die Menschen hier sind auch wirklich stolz darauf dann,
deutsche Produkte und deutsche Geräte benutzen zu dürfen,
weil sie sagen, wenn es aus Deutschland kommt,
dann muss es eine Topqualität haben.
Andererseits kann man aber wirklich an einer Hand abzählen,
wie viele türkische Marken es gibt,
die wirklich weltweit bekannt sind und renommiert sind.
Und das ist wirklich superschade.
Aber eine türkische Marke,
die kennt, glaube ich, jeder von euch
und das ist die Marke Paşabahçe.
Als ich meinem Papa erzählt habe,
dass wir mit Paşabahçe zusammenarbeiten,
dass die uns beliefern
und sogar eigene Produkte für uns herstellen,
da war er echt zu Tränen gerührt.
Und das bin ich auch.
Ich bin echt megastolz darauf, das sagen zu dürfen.
Deswegen wollte ich euch mit in die Türkei nehmen,
hier nach Istanbul.
Denn hier hat alles mit Paşabahçe
vor vielen, vielen Jahren angefangen.
Aber Paşabahçe ist nicht einfach nur eine türkische Marke.
Sie beliefern wirklich über 160 Länder der Welt.
Überall kennt man die Gläser, überall das Geschirr.
Und vor allem würde ich echt wetten,
dass in jedem Haushalt, auch bei euch zu Hause,
mindestens ein Glas von Paşabahçe bei euch steht.
Denn sie machen nicht nur Eigenlabels,
sondern produzieren auch
für viele, viele weitere Marken der Welt.
Und ich bin jetzt hier,
um euch die Produktvielfalt von Paşabahçe zu zeigen
angefangen natürlich beim ganz traditionellen Teeglas,
welches ihr auch bei uns im Shop bekommt
und natürlich auch kennt,
das Sally- und das Murat-Glas.
Aber Paşabahçe hat auch Produkte,
die zum Beispiel aus Borosilikat hergestellt werden,
wie Ofenformen oder auch meinen eigenen Messbecher.
Und gerade jetzt zu Corona-Zeiten muss ich auch dazusagen:
Wir haben beim Dreh wirklich extrem darauf aufgepasst,
dass wir wirklich immer Mundschutz tragen,
den Nasen-Mund-Schutz,
und nur für Kamerazwecke die Masken abnehmen.
Aber hier in der Türkei muss ich auch sagen,
dass die Auflagen und die Regelungen
wirklich ganz, ganz streng sind.
Selbst in der Öffentlichkeit, draußen auf der Straße,
überall muss Maske getragen werden.
Deswegen: Wir haben es wirklich
nicht auf die leichte Schulter genommen,
sondern gehen sehr verantwortungsbewusst damit um.
Ich würde sagen,
ich genieße jetzt hier noch meinen Çay am Bosporus
und dann nehme ich euch mit in die Welt von Paşabahçe.
[Musik]
Okay, ich muss euch leider vorwarnen.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es so schön ist.
>> MURAT: Also
>> SALLY: Gehen wir einfach rein.
>> MURAT: ich weiß jetzt schon, es wird eskalieren
und es ist...
>> SALLY: Habe ich hier meinen Geldbeutel drin?
>> MURAT: Nein, der ist im Auto.
In irgendeinem Auto, fährt hier irgendwo rum.
Ja. Aber der ist weggefahren.
>> SALLY: Wir gehen jetzt rein und nehmen euch mit.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich sehe jetzt schon,
es ist einfach mehr als nur Glas.
Wo ist hier der Eingang?
Da.
[Musik]
Ich nehme euch jetzt einfach mit.
Also wir machen jetzt einfach so
so eine komplette Shop-Tour,
weil, ich glaube, ich kann kein Regal hier auslassen.
[Musik]
Die passen so perfekt in mein Wohnzimmer.
Wenn es Murat nicht sieht, kaufe ich das alles.
[Musik]
Ich bin so anfällig für Kakteen.
>> SARAH: Sally?
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> SARAH: Da gibt es eine Katzenkollektion.
>> SALLY: Nein!
>> SARAH: Doch.
>> SALLY: Zeig.
>> SARAH: Da hinten.
>> SALLY: Zeig, zeig, zeig.
[Musik]
Ja. Guck mal, diese Katzen-Collection
oder auch das hier.
Und zwar ist das ein berühmter Maler,
ein Künstler in der Türkei, Selçuk Demirel.
Und er hat diese ganze Serie hier designt.
Also Paşabahçe arbeitet auch mit verschiedenen Künstlern.
Die machen dann eigene Kollektionen.
Und ich finde das echt schön,
vor allem, weil dann alles so individuell wird.
Richtig tolles Design, gefällt mir auch echt gut.
[Musik]
Borcam, das ist das komplette Glas, was eben getempert ist,
das heißt aus Borosilikatglas.
Das ist hitzebeständig, ist säurefest
und es ist einfach so das Stabilste,
was man bekommt, was eben an Glas ist.
Und daraus wird zum Beispiel
auch unser Messbecher hergestellt.
Der ist auch aus Borosilikatglas,
damit, wenn ihr auch heiße Flüssigkeiten einfüllt,
eine Suppe drin püriert
oder das Ganze sogar erwärmt im Backofen,
eben das Glas nicht zerspringt.
Also es ist ein ganz spezielles Verfahren,
sind auch ganz spezielle Materialien,
die eben in dem Glas benutzt werden,
ganz spezielle Rohstoffe.
Und das ist so die Borcam-Serie.
Und da gibt es einfach verschiedene Modelle.
Wir hatten uns auch für die hier entschieden
für den Onlineshop und für den Shop in Mannheim,
weil ich die einfach megaschön finde.
Denn die meisten haben ja immer runde Auflaufformen
oder so eckige, die aber nicht ganz wirklich eckig sind.
Und da ist Paşabahçe so der einzige Hersteller,
der diesen 90°-Winkel hinbekommt,
richtig schöne Ecken.
Also da so ein Tiramisu rein
oder Brownies oder andere tolle Rezepte,
megacool!
Und jetzt habe ich erfahren,
wir sind die einzigen in Deutschland, die die verkaufen.
[Musik]
Plötzlich interessiert mich Geschichte doch.
Josh,
>> JOSH: Ja?
>> SALLY: ich bin dein Vater.
>> JOSH: Was es alles aus Glas gibt.
>> SALLY: Mega!
[Musik]
Die sind richtig schön!
>> SARAH: Hm, aber was bedeutet das eigentlich genau?
Also wir haben das an unseren Olivenölflaschen dran.
>> SALLY: Ja, das fragen uns tatsächlich
auch viele Zuschauer.
Und zwar hat das eine lange Geschichte.
Vor Jahrtausenden war es nämlich so, dass, wenn Menschen
mit einem blauen Auge auf die Welt kamen,
dachte man, wenn zum Beispiel dieser Mensch dann
zu jemandem sagt: "Oh, wow, du hast aber schöne Haare",
dass dann der Blick dieser blauen Augen
einfach was Böses macht.
Das heißt, ich sage zu dir: "Du hast schöne Haare",
und dann fallen dir alle Haare aus.
Und da hatte man einfach Angst davor.
Das heißt, alle Menschen mit blauen Augen
vor Jahrtausenden waren praktisch
– die hatten dieses böse Auge.
Und um sich davor zu schützen,
hat man eben das blaue Auge gemacht.
Und das kennt man auch so.
Auch heute wird das noch so gemacht.
Wenn ein Baby auf die Welt kommt
oder man ein Auto sich kauft oder ein Haus baut,
dann ist es einfach so, dass man ein blaues Auge dranhängt,
und dieses blaue Auge schützt dich dann
vor allen bösen Blicken.
>> SARAH: Man sagt ja auch so: "Mach kein Auge", oder?
>> SALLY: Genau. "Mach kein Auge", sagt man so.
Und deswegen das blaue Auge.
Und daher ist das eben auch. Ja.
Und dann sagt man eben noch dazu: "Maşallah."
Das heißt: "Gott wollte es so. Deswegen ist es so."
>> SARAH: Maşallah.
>> SALLY: Und deswegen, wenn ich jetzt zu Sarah sage:
"Sarah, du hast so schöne Haare, maşallah."
>> SARAH: Dann fallen sie mir nicht aus.
>> SALLY: Und dann hänge ich dir ein Auge dran.
>> SARAH: Häng mir am besten das dran.
Dann laufe ich so.
>> SALLY: Und dann schützt es sie vor dem bösen Auge.
Ja.
[Musik]
Jetzt habt ihr mal die ganzen Eindrücke hier gesehen.
Also ich selbst bin megaüberwältigt.
Ich würde jetzt aber mal sagen,
wir gehen jetzt ins Hauptquartier von Paşabahçe.
Ich nehme euch mal mit.
Aber dafür müssen wir einmal kurz quer durch Istanbul durch.
[Musik]
Wir sind jetzt hier am Paşabahçe-Gebäude angekommen.
Und natürlich herrschen hier
ganz große Sicherheitsmaßnahmen.
Das heißt, am Eingang
muss direkt jeder seine Taschen abgeben,
es gibt eine Personenkontrolle
und, weil eben momentan noch Pandemiezeiten sind,
wird auch gleich Fieber gemessen,
um einfach sicherzustellen, dass jeder, der hier ankommt,
zum einen gesund ist
und keine gefährlichen Gegenstände mit sich trägt.
Merhaba!
>> MITARBEITER: Merhaba!
>> SALLY: Direkt am Eingang
werden dann auch noch die Personendaten erfasst.
Man bekommt einen Besucherausweis
und darf dann das Gebäude betreten.
Teşekkürler.
[Musik]
Wir sind jetzt hier im Headquarter,
also im Bürogebäude von Paşabahçe.
Und ich muss sagen, wir als Team sind megabeeindruckt,
weil es einfach so ein megamodernes Gebäude ist,
richtig schön und groß.
Und vielleicht ganz kurz zum Hintergrund:
Die Marke Paşabahçe gehört zu Şişecam.
Und Şişecam ist einer der größten
Glaswarenhersteller der Welt.
Und ich finde,
da kann man schon ein bisschen stolz darauf sein,
vor allem, weil ja wirklich auch jeder von euch
mindestens ein Glas zu Hause von Paşabahçe hat.
Und jetzt, würde ich sagen, gehen wir in den Showroom,
schauen uns hier alles mal an
und ich lasse mir einfach mal erklären,
was denn hier alles passiert.
[Musik]
Im Showroom treffe ich jetzt die Menschen,
die hinter den einzelnen Produktbereichen stehen.
Asli zum Beispiel ist Produktleiterin
im Bereich Trends und Neuheiten.
[Musik]
Hier in der Mitte sieht man immer so die aktuellsten Trends.
Also das sind jetzt die Trends für 2020.
Die Trends für 2021 sind auch schon auf dem Weg.
Und da kommt es eben immer darauf an.
Da kommen neue Designs zum Beispiel.
Und gerade bei Geschirr, bei Gläsern ist natürlich wichtig,
dass die Farben lebensmittelecht sind.
Und hier wird es einfach so gemacht,
dass die Farben immer schön außen aufgedruckt werden.
Das heißt, die Lebensmittel kommen auch
gar nicht direkt mit der Farbe in Kontakt.
[Musik]
Emre ist seit über 20 Jahren im Verkauf zuständig
und ist unser direkter Ansprechpartner bei Paşabahçe
und mittlerweile, muss ich auch echt sagen,
ein richtig guter Freund geworden.
Das muss ich echt kurz erklären.
Hier haben wir die Borcam-Serie,
also, was ich ja auch schon erklärt habe,
aus Borosilikat, wirklich sehr hitzebeständig,
temperaturbeständig und eben auch säurefest.
Und das sind ja diese tollen Auflaufformen
und die Ofenformen.
Und hier haben wir jetzt eine Non-Stick-Serie.
Und die ist ganz besonders,
weil hier eine Beschichtung mit drin ist
und dann eben auch nichts mehr am Glas haftet.
Das Ganze ist natürlich so eine Antihaftbeschichtung,
die aber eben gesundheitlich wirklich unbedenklich ist.
Selbst wenn ihr mit einem Messer mal drin schneidet
und die Beschichtung zerkratzt und zerstört,
ist es eben nicht gesundheitsschädlich.
Und was das an Backeigenschaften verbessert, ist Folgendes:
Glas ist ja wirklich superglatt
und wenn ihr zum Beispiel einen Biskuit im Glas backt,
dann rutscht der eigentlich am Rand immer wieder runter,
kann gar nicht hochklettern.
Und was man hier eben hat:
Diese Beschichtung, die ist so leicht angeraut.
Das heißt, da kann der Teig
einfach schön am Rand hochklettern, rutscht nicht runter,
löst sich aber nach dem Backen perfekt wieder ab.
Und deswegen hat man hier
eben diese Beschichtung mit reingepackt.
Und ich werde das auf jeden Fall daheim austesten.
>> EMRE: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und wenn es cool ist,
dann nehmen wir es direkt mit auf bei uns.
Also für mich ist das jetzt auch so eine kleine Abenteuerreise.
Denn ich habe in Deutschland
natürlich auch nicht alles an Produkten gesehen,
selbst auf der Ambiente nicht.
Und jetzt kann ich mich hier
so ein bisschen entfalten und entdecken.
Und alles, was ich cool finde,
nehmen wir dann einfach direkt mit auf.
>> EMRE: Wenn man Metall benutzt,
dann erhitzt das Metall sich sehr schnell.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EMRE: Also bleibt der Teig in der Mitte
>> SALLY: Genau.
>> EMRE: nicht
– erhitzt das nicht
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> EMRE: mit der gleichen Proportion.
>> SALLY: Stimmt.
>> EMRE: Aber bei Glas erhitzt das sich langsam,
sodass du die Zeit hast,
dass der Teig innen drin sich auch noch...
>> SALLY: Ja.
Sehr cool!
Ich probiere die auf jeden Fall aus.
Vor allem finde ich die optisch voll schön,
so weiß und schwarz.
[Musik]
Ich habe gerade so
mein Auge hier so drüber,
d-d-dim, d-d-dim, d-d-dim,
und sehe diese Rührschüssel.
Und was sage ich immer?
Was sage ich immer?
"Man hätte auch eine größere Rührschüssel nehmen können",
weil bei mir beim Rühren immer alles rausspritzt.
>> JOSH: Denkst du, du verkleckerst damit nichts mehr?
>> SALLY: Ich denke, ich verkleckere damit nichts mehr.
[Musik]
Arzu ist Leiterin im Bereich Marketing
und erklärte mir hier gerade
eine der beiden großen Innovationen in diesem Jahr.
[Musik]
Und zwar ist hier die Kollektion.
Die Aware-Kollektion wird zu 100 Prozent
aus recyceltem Glas gewonnen und hergestellt.
Und da war einfach die Schwierigkeit immer bisher darin:
Bei der Glasproduktion werden immer
maximal 5 Prozent Altglas benutzt,
um eben neues Glas herzustellen.
Und hier hat man einfach 100 Prozent Altglas,
weil Paşabahçe sagt, alles, was wir auf der Welt hinterlassen,
darüber sollte man sich eben viele Gedanken machen.
Und deswegen nehmen sie das komplette Altglas,
schmelzen es ein
und haben jetzt hier einfach
eine schöne Produktionsserie gemacht.
Und nicht nur das Glas ist 100 Prozent recycelt,
sondern auch die Verpackung.
Also da stimmt einfach wirklich die komplette Geschichte
und man hat hier einfach ein Produkt,
was zu 100 Prozent nachhaltig ist.
[Musik]
Barkin ist für den internationalen Markt zuständig
und erklärt mir hier gerade
die zweite große Innovation in diesem Jahr.
[Musik]
Innovation bedeutet ja auch,
dass man spontan auf Geschehnisse reagiert.
Und Paşabahçe sagt sich:
"Wir sind so ein tolles Weltunternehmen,
Vorreiter und natürlich auch Vorbild."
Und deswegen nehmen sie die Pandemie
natürlich auch sehr ernst.
Das bedeutet, sie haben hier jetzt eine Innovation,
die nennt sich V-Block.
Und oftmals werden ja Krankheiten
über den Kontakt vieler Menschen übertragen.
Man fasst einen Gegenstand an,
da setzen sich Viren drauf ab,
dann kommt ein anderer Mensch, nimmt es in die Hand
und dann ist eben dieser Mensch direkt angesteckt.
Und hier ist jetzt eine besondere Beschichtung drauf,
auf den Gläsern,
sodass einfach der Hand- und Hautkontakt eben
die Viren nicht mehr überträgt.
Das heißt, hier ist ein antibakterielle
und antivirale Beschichtung drauf.
Und da sind sie wirklich Vorreiter,
werden es jetzt zuerst mal in der Türkei austesten,
jetzt in der Testphase,
und danach geht das Ganze eben auch in die ganze Welt.
[Musik]
Guck mal, selbst die Pfälzer Dubbegläser
werden hier hergestellt.
[Musik]
Mit Pelin gehe ich jetzt noch gemeinsam alle Produkte durch,
die ich in meinem Onlineshop
und auch stationär in Mannheim aufnehmen möchte.
[Musik]
Wir wollten auf jeden Fall Espressogläser.
Denn ich finde es einfach wunderschön.
Schaut mal.
Weil normalerweise sind Espressotassen
halt immer aus Porzellan und das finde ich echt langweilig.
>> SARAH: Ja, was Besonderes.
>> SALLY: Also die finde ich schön.
Aber ich bin ein Megafan auch von der hier.
Die ist so schön rundlich geformt.
Ja, Sarah, was sagst du?
>> SARAH: Also ich bin für die.
Weil wir fanden
– ursprünglich
>> SARAH: haben wir die gesehen.
>> SALLY: Ja, ursprünglich war da...
>> SARAH: Und dann haben wir gesagt,
wir wollen so eine aus Glas.
Und ich finde, das ist die perfekte Mischung.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ich darf jetzt euch mitnehmen
und wir dürfen jetzt sehen, wie Glas entsteht.
Wir sind das erste Filmteam,
was die heiligen Hallen von Paşabahçe sehen darf.
Also kommt mit und entdeckt mit mir, wie Glas entsteht.
[Musik]
Jetzt sind wir in der Produktion,
ziehen alle Sicherheitskleidung an
und dann geht es los.
[Musik]
Hier steht überall, dass man hier nicht filmen
und auch nicht fotografieren darf.
Aber wir sind das erste Kamerateam,
was in die heiligen Hallen darf
und die Produktion sich anschauen darf.
Und da nehme ich euch jetzt mit
und zeige euch, wie Glas im Allgemeinen hergestellt wird,
und vor allem, wie Borosilikatglas hergestellt wird
und was das Besondere daran ist.
Kommt mit.
[Musik]
Je nachdem, was für ein Glas man natürlich herstellen möchte,
sind natürlich die Zutaten andere.
Der Hauptbestandteil ist aber Quarzsand.
Das seht ihr hier im Hintergrund.
Quarzsand sieht so aus im rohen Zustand.
Und der wird dann gemischt mit Natriumcarbonat
und auch mit ein bisschen altem Glas.
Das heißt, es wird auch viel Glas recycelt.
[Musik]
Hier sieht man jetzt auch das ganze Glas,
was eben kaputtgegangen ist
und als Recyclingmaterial zurückkommt.
Da gibt es auch ganz viele Unterschiede.
Zum einen gibt es Glas, was eben für Trinkgläser benutzt wird,
und dann gibt es auch noch das getemperte Glas,
also das Borosilikatglas.
Und da sieht man auch den Unterschied.
Denn das Borosilikatglas
– da sieht man auch die ganzen Ofenformen,
die ganzen Figuren und Modelle.
Denn das Glas geht einfach nicht so schnell kaputt.
Das heißt...
Wirklich?!
Kannst du mich vorwarnen?
>> MURAT: Ah, Entschuldigung.
Ich wollte das schon immer...
>> SALLY: Ich bin gerade mitten, weißt, ich bin...
>> MURAT: Ich wollte das schon immer
mal in meinem Leben machen.
Hast du das auch mal gemacht?
Scherben bringt Glück. Mach mal kurz.
>> SALLY: Echt jetzt?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Soll ich?
>> SALLY: Einfach mal ausrasten einmal in meinem Leben?
Okay, ich raste einmal komplett aus.
Ich habe es zerstört, Murat.
Komm, jetzt gehen wir rein,
schauen uns an, wie die Rohstoffe vermischt werden
und wie aus diesem ganzen Material hier Glas entsteht.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Oh, die ist noch gut.
>> SALLY: Murat, komm!
>> MURAT: Ja, warte doch.
Warte kurz.
Meine Tasse.
>> SALLY: Murat, komm!
>> MURAT: Ja, ich komme.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hier ist das jetzt im Prinzip wie in der Backstube.
Hier entstehen Rezepte.
Je nachdem, welches Glas ich herstellen möchte,
werden eben auch verschiedene Zutaten zusammengemischt.
Das kann man echt vergleichen
wie beim Pralinenmachen oder beim Kuchenbacken.
Und ihr seht hier die einzelnen Silos.
Da sind die Rohstoffe drin.
Die werden von außen mit Lkws angeliefert,
werden dann per Luftdruck nach oben gepumpt,
landen hier in den Silos.
Und hier kommen die einzelnen Zutaten dann zusammen,
werden hier unten vermischt in einem Mixer
und gehen dann über Förderbänder nach drüben
in die Schmelzschale.
[Musik]
Hier seht ihr jetzt die Förderbänder.
Über die Förderbänder gelangen die Backrohstoffe,
also die Backmischung gelangt dann
nach oben in die Schmelzschale.
Aber das kann euch der Murat viel besser erklären.
>> MURAT: Ja, weil ich
– jetzt mal ohne Spaß.
Ich habe das echt früher,
ich habe früher immer diese Rollen repariert.
Ich weiß noch ganz genau,
ich musste die mit der Stange immer anheben.
Die Bänder habe ich ausgetauscht.
Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, hier sieht es extrem sauber aus.
Also es ist eine krasse Staubentwicklung,
was hier nachher passiert.
Und das ist zum Beispiel so ein Sicherheitsseil.
Wenn hier irgendwas sein sollte,
wenn hier irgendjemand ist, irgendwas
und zieht an diesem Seil,
bleibt die ganze Anlage komplett stehen.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Wow!
Also komm. Wir schalten jetzt die Maschinen an.
>> MURAT: Ja, schalten wir sie mal an.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Okay, halt! Stopp, stopp, stopp!
Bevor es jetzt allerdings zum Schmelzen geht der Rohstoffe,
möchte ich euch zeigen,
dass es einen ganz wichtigen Zwischenschritt gibt.
Und den wird euch aber mein Vorgesetzter,
der Herr Özcan, erklären.
Herr Özcan, darf ich die Filmcrew zu Ihnen reinschicken?
>> MURAT: Frau Özcan, haben Sie alles gemischt?
>> SALLY: Ja, alle Rohstoffe sind vermischt.
>> MURAT: Alles klar. Ich lasse den Mischer mal laufen, ja?
>> SALLY: Alles klar.
Ihr dürft rein.
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt sind wir an einer Stelle,
ungelogen, das war mal früher mein Beruf.
Und zwar als Verfahrensmechaniker für Steine und Erden
habe ich ein PLS bedient.
Das nennt sich PLS.
Das ist eine Abkürzung für Prozessleitsystem.
Alles, was hier passiert, alles, was hier gemischt wird,
und die ganzen Mischvorgänge
sehen wir hier visualisiert:
Wie ist die Rezeptur?
Wie lange wird gemixt?
Wie ist die Luftfeuchte?
Wie ist alles Drum und Dran?
Genau.
Und hier sehe ich das.
Selbst wenn ein kleines Motörchen hier eine Störung bekommt,
sehe ich das sofort angezeigt und weiß es dann sofort
und schicke dann die Monteure raus.
Hasan, Motor 4 an der Steuerung 7 im Mischer 3 bitte.
Ist kaputtgegangen.
Bitte, bitte, bitte reparieren.
Ja.
So.
Auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, ist das ganz cool,
eine Visualisierung zu haben.
Es ist auch eine Arbeitssicherheit.
Man weiß, wo man arbeitet.
Und das machen die hier ganz cool, muss ich sagen.
Also ich könnte mich
– ich könnte hier noch...
Zwei Pommes bitte, eine Pizza und eine Köfte im Brötchen.
Danke schön.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: So sieht übrigens eine typische Schmelzschale,
ein Schmelzofen aus.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Der hier wird jetzt nicht mehr benutzt,
aber hier wurden früher 75 Tonnen Glas geschmolzen,
also Rohstoffe geschmolzen.
Heißes Glas war hier drin.
Und ich finde es krass, wie es hier aussieht.
Weil der komplette Boden besteht aus Glas.
Da hinten seht ihr auch die Löcher.
Da kam das heiße Feuer raus,
1.500°C.
Ich will mir nicht vorstellen, wie heiß es hier drin war.
>> MURAT: Das ist ein richtig krasser Job.
Also ehrlich, Respekt vor allen Menschen, die hier arbeiten.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ich finde das immer der Wahnsinn.
>> MURAT: Richtig, richtig krass!
>> SALLY: Richtig harte körperliche Arbeit.
>> MURAT: Und ich schwitze hier,
obwohl der Ofen gar nicht an ist.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ich schwitze hier wie ein Schwein,
obwohl ich ein Moslem bin.
Ja.
Wahnsinn!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ich erkläre euch kurz am Beispiel
von Borosilikatglas, wie Glas entsteht.
Der Name setzt sich aus den Komponenten
mit den größten Anteilen zusammen:
Siliciumdioxid, also Quarzsand,
und Bortrioxid, also Bor und Sauerstoff.
Dazu kommen dann noch glänzende Metalle
wie zum Beispiel Beryllium, Magnesium oder Calcium.
Und wenn man dann noch andere Stoffe beigefügt,
kann man die Härte, Farbe
und die Glaskorrosion beeinflussen.
Aber wieso stellt man überhaupt Borosilikatglas her?
Borosilikat ist aufgrund des Borgehalts
besonders beständig gegen Säure,
Chemikalien und pharmazeutische Produkte.
Außerdem springt das Glas nicht
bei extrem plötzlicher Wärme oder auch Kälte.
Und deswegen ist es ideal für die Küche
und eben auch zum Backen und Kochen geeignet.
[Musik]
Die Inhaltsstoffe werden vermischt
und bei circa 1.600°C geschmolzen.
Das Glas fließt durch mehrere Kanäle
und wird dabei auf 1.200°C gekühlt,
damit eine formbare Masse entsteht.
Das kann man so ein bisschen vergleichen
wie mit dem Temperieren von Schokolade.
[Musik]
Und dann kann es auch schon direkt ans Portionieren gehen.
Das noch sehr heiße, flüssige Glas
fällt als Tropfen in die Form.
Und dieser heiße, rote Glastropfen
stellt auch das Paşabahçe-Logo dar.
[Musik]
Das Glas kann nun entweder geblasen,
gepresst oder gesponnen werden.
Wir stellen hier jetzt gerade
Borcam-Ofenformen aus Borosilikatglas her.
Hier wird das Glas gepresst,
um die gewünschte Form zu erhalten.
Nach dem Pressen haben die Formen
aber noch Unebenheiten, die durch eine weitere Fahrt
und durch starke Hitze ebenerdig gemacht werden.
Das konnten wir uns auch im Detail anschauen,
aber wir mussten unsere Augen
vor den heißen Flammen schützen.
[Musik]
Ein Arbeiter prüft dann auch direkt,
ob die Maschinen korrekt laufen
und das Glas die richtige Form behält.
[Musik]
Falls nicht, kann er die Maschine einfach anders einstellen,
um das Problem dann direkt zu beheben.
[Musik]
Nachdem die Ofenformen dann abgekühlt sind,
werden sie ein letztes Mal kontrolliert
und fehlerhafte Ware wird dann eben noch aussortiert.
[Musik]
Die Qualitätskontrolle findet
nicht nur bei Borcam-Formen statt,
sondern auch bei allen anderen
Glasprodukten von Paşabahçe.
Mitarbeiter, aber auch Maschinen kontrollieren die Ware,
damit der Kunde ein perfektes Produkt am Ende
auf seinem Tisch oder in seinem Wohnzimmer stehen hat.
[Musik]
Außerdem wird im Labor die allgemeine Robustheit
der verschiedenen Produkte getestet,
um sie eben auch stets zu verbessern
und Fehler auszuschließen.
Um eine einwandfreie Qualität zu gewährleisten,
gibt es Stoß-, Schlag- oder auch Falltests
und auch die Glasstärke wird immer wieder kontrolliert.
[Musik]
Jetzt waren wir bei der Qualitätskontrolle.
Die Messbecher sind einwandfrei.
Das Borosilikatglas ist wirklich super.
Alles perfekt bestanden,
hitzefest, säurebeständig, bruchsicher.
Und jetzt kommen die hier auf ein Förderband.
Denn, ihr seht schon,
ein Messbecher ist erst dann ein Messbecher,
wenn natürlich auch eine Messskala drauf ist.
Hier wird jetzt der Druck draufgedruckt
und zwar hier mit drei Farben.
Das heißt, wir haben einmal das Sally-Logo in Magenta,
wir haben das Paşabahçe-Logo in Rot
und wir haben noch eine Schrift in Schwarz.
Und das ist wirklich einmalig.
Und man musste hier auch
zwei Arbeitsschritte noch mal zusätzlich dazu machen,
um den dreifarbigen Druck hinzubekommen.
Ich glaube, wir müssen schneller arbeiten, Murat.
>> MURAT: Ja, Sally, mach. Komm.
[Musik]
Und hier kommen dann die wunderschönen Messbecher
von Paşabahçe und Sally heraus.
Alle schön bedruckt mit dem dreifarbigen Druck,
was wirklich einzigartig auf der Welt ist.
Da kommen sie dann übers Förderband
hin zur Verpackungsstation.
Und da gehen wir jetzt gleich als Nächstes hin.
[Musik]
Also, wenn wir schon da sind,
dann verpacken wir natürlich auch selber,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: würde ich sagen.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Warte kurz! Warte kurz!
>> SALLY: Komm.
[Musik]
Jetzt sind wir wieder zu Hause
>> MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: und haben alles mitgebracht.
Ihr seht jetzt auch:
So eine Glasproduktion ist ziemlich aufwendig,
sehr schweißtreibend.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also ich muss sagen, wir waren ja dort,
es war auch superinteressant,
aber jeden Tag in der heißen Fabrik zu arbeiten,
das ist schon Wahnsinn,
also wirklich auch eine Belastung für den Körper.
>> MURAT: Ja. Und kennt ihr den Spruch:
Schafft dein Vater
– ist dein Vater Glaser?
Kennt ihr das?
Der stimmt hier wirklich.
Und es war wirklich also eine krasse Aktion,
richtig heiß da drin.
Also wirklich ein Knochenjob.
>> SALLY: Es war echt der Hammer.
Aber ihr seht auch,
dass Paşabahçe wirklich ein total innovatives
und auch sehr zukunftsorientiertes Unternehmen ist.
Gerade, wenn ich jetzt bedenke V-Block zum Beispiel,
eben das Glas, was speziell beschichtet wurde.
>> MURAT: Also antibakteriell,
richtig mit einer Beschichtung drauf.
>> SALLY: Genau, um gerade jetzt zu Pandemiezeiten
eben keine Bakterien oder Viren weiterzugeben.
Also da denken die ja schon mit.
>> MURAT: Oder das Glas, was zu 100 Prozent recycelt ist,
aber trotzdem, dass man noch durchschauen konnte.
Das wusste ich nämlich nicht, dass man wirklich
– dass ein 100 Prozent recyceltes Glas
eigentlich nicht durchsichtig mehr ist.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Und das macht mich, muss ich sagen, megastolz,
dass Paşabahçe eben,
einer der größten Glashersteller der Welt,
uns als Partner auch gewählt hat
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: und wir mit ihnen arbeiten dürfen.
>> MURAT: Vor allem mich.
>> SALLY: Ja, und wir sogar schon einzelne
– wie sage ich da? –
Kooperationsprodukte sogar haben.
Also wir haben ja wirklich zusammen diesen Glasmessbecher
>> MURAT: Den habt ihr ja jetzt gesehen bei der Produktion.
>> SALLY: aus Borosilikat hergestellt.
Den haben wir jetzt auch schon,
weil viele danach gefragt haben,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: in einem Liter,
mit einem Liter Volumen hergestellt
und werden das jetzt gerade produzieren lassen.
>> MURAT: Der kommt erst so ab März.
Wie gesagt, haben viele von euch gewünscht,
also mit einem Liter.
Und diese kleinen Messbecher.
>> SALLY: Ja, weil für Kleinstmengen
halt auch die kleinen Messbecher megapraktisch sind,
haben wir die jetzt auch noch mit entwickelt.
Und die werden jetzt auch demnächst kommen.
Also wirklich Topqualität, Topware
und einfach auch ein Topunternehmen,
was wir da besucht haben.
Wir haben uns jetzt gedacht,
machen wir ein schönes Gewinnspiel, ein Paket für euch.
Und zwar würden wir euch
dieses Zweierset der Borcam-Ofenformen geben.
Und da ist ja auch das Besondere,
dass die wirklich einen schönen rechten Winkel haben.
Denn normalerweise sind Auflaufformen aus Glas
gerade von anderen Herstellern immer nicht eckig,
sondern wirklich so abgerundet,
weil es eben vom Pressvorgang nicht geht.
Aber Borcam beziehungsweise Paşabahçe
hat das super hingekriegt.
Dann gibt es den Borosilikat-Messbecher dazu
und sogar noch die Teegläser.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Sollen wir da einfach beide
oder dürfen sie es aussuchen?
>> MURAT: Nee, machen wir beide. Komm.
>> SALLY: Gell? Machen wir beide.
>> MURAT: So. Das sieht dann so aus.
>> SALLY: Murat- und Sally-Gläser.
>> MURAT: Zack.
Genau.
>> SALLY: Und das gibt es ja alles noch nicht.
Das gibt es erst bald.
Von daher können wir das nicht mit verlosen leider.
Da müsst ihr euch leider noch ein bisschen gedulden.
>> MURAT: Und die Frage lautet:
>> SALLY: Ich würde sagen, genau:
Was ist die Besonderheit von Borosilikat?
Also schreibt es uns gerne in die Kommentare.
Und ich meine,
wir können das ja einfach fünfmal verlosen, oder?
>> MURAT: Ja, also fünfmal verlosen wir es.
Das heißt, wir werden es dann
zweimal auf Facebook und dreimal auf YouTube.
Oder?
>> SALLY: Wir machen sechsmal.
Wir man zwei Facebook, zwei Instagram, zwei YouTube.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Dann ist es ausgeglichen.
>> MURAT: Genau. Beantwortet die Frage.
Und das wird eine coole Geschichte.
Und wir freuen uns auf weitere Dinge.
In unserem Shop gibt es übrigens
schon einiges von Paşabahçe.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Das heißt Gläser, Auflaufformen
und alles Drum und Dran.
>> SALLY: Und schaut gerne mal wirklich vorbei.
>> MURAT: Schaut mal vorbei.
>> SALLY: Und schaut auch gerne mal in eure Schränke
oder da, wo ihr eben seid,
und schreibt uns mal, was ihr denn zu Hause...
>> MURAT: Und schickt uns Fotos, wenn ihr es gerade habt,
>> SALLY: Ja, was ihr zu Hause entdeckt habt,
>> MURAT: ob ihr es gefunden habt, ob ihr es entdeckt habt.
>> SALLY: Also viel Spaß mit dem Gewinnspiel,
viel Erfolg und vielen, vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen!
Es war echt eine wunderschöne Reise.
>> MURAT: Für uns auch wirklich war das ganz
– immer was Neues zu lernen genauso wie ihr.
Ihr habt gesehen, wie so was
– keiner wusste, wie es eigentlich hergestellt wird.
Was machen wir als Nächstes?
>> SALLY: Werden wir sehen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wir sind offen für alles.
>> SALLY: Bis bald!
>> MURAT: Bis dann!
Tschau!
Liebe Grüße übrigens in die Türkei!
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Goodbye!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Zeig.
>> MURAT: Nein, nein, nein!
Komm, komm, komm.
Komm.
>> SALLY: Eine Cataleya-Collection!
>> SARAH: Die ist nur für Cataleya gemacht worden.
>> SALLY: Denn Sarah hat, wie ihr wisst,
die schönste Katze der Welt.
>> SARAH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hier ein Bilder.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Das Video kann sich nun
um ein paar Stunden verzögern.
>> SARAH: Ich kann auch Videos einfügen.
Videos habe ich auch.